salut samsung le galaxy note 9 vous en
ai parlé déjà il ya quelques temps on a
toujours un écran super amoled format 18
points 5/9 et il est enfin sorti comme
une bonne nouvelle n'arrive jamais seule
j'ai reçu le galaxy note 9 et des coques
tout ça je vous en parle maintenant mais
avant toute chose je vous présente
nouveau générique parce que c'est
aujourd'hui le lancement officiel de la
saison 2 de monsieur greu vous ne payez
ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
ça fait super longtemps que je travaille
sur la deuxième saison et je suis très
heureux pouvoir la lancer officiellement
aujourd'hui alors il va y avoir pas mal
de choses qui vont évoluer
pas mal de nouveautés je vais vous
parler d'ici quelques instants du galaxy
note 9 qui est juste là je voulais
garder imprimeur pour qu'on puisse se
l'ouvrir ans on regarde alors on va
beaucoup parler dans un premier temps on
va l'ouvrir on va le tester on va voir
pas mal de choses et on va faire une
deuxième vidéo dédiée uniquement à la
partie photo vidéo parce que je pense
que c'est vraiment un appareil qui
mérite une vidéo dédiée pour la photo et
pour la vidéo mais ça ne ment pas d'ici
quelques secondes
juste avant j'ai absolument vous parler
de cette fameuse rentrée et vous
présenter les points qui vont changer
si vous êtes déjà un abonné un habitué
de la chaîne vous savez que je parle
beaucoup de smartphones c'est l'objet
technologique qu'on a tous avec nous
donc forcément quelque chose
d'extrêmement passionnant puis c'est
toujours intéressant de voir un petit
peu ce qui se trame ce qui arrive
qu'elles sont un peu les nouveautés ne
va pas parler que de ça cette année on
va aussi parler de plein d'autres sujets
là je vous présente la votre nouvel ami
du studio qui notre autre que le
président des états unis d'amérique
je vous présente donald trump qui vous
passe le bonjour on va donc parler de
smartphones on va parler de tablettes on
va aussi parler d'ordinateur on va
parler de la maison connectée au travers
dans cinq connectés on va parler par
extension de robotique parce que les
robots vont arriver chez nous d'ici
quelques temps il y en a qui va arriver
très bientôt sur la chaîne écrit ses
pouvoir à voir avec moi donc on va
pouvoir en parler tester ce robot ouvre
un petit peu comment fonctionne la
robotique et qu'est ce qu'elle peut nous
apporter aujourd'hui chez nous parce
qu'on peut dès aujourd'hui à voir des
robots
si on le souhaite on va aussi parler des
voitures du futur pour va parler de
technologie au sens large et ça vous
allez voir c'est extrêmement passionnant
on va parler de tout ça au travers de
voyage aura forcément des vidéos qui
veulent tourner ici dans ce que j en
train de peu 2 de finir de réaménager
pour l'instant c'est encore un peu le
bordel non que je garde un peu un plan
paris si vous connaissez si vous avez
déjà suivi de l'autre côté derrière sait
pas encore il parie pas présentable mais
je travaille vraiment tout seul soit
bientôt vous emmener avec moi dès demain
on va et en dehors
locaux ont emballé au palais de tokyo à
paris pour aller voir pour qu phone
c'est la nouvelle marque été lancé par
shionogi
on va les voir leur nouveau smartphone
cette nouvelle marque on va voir si elle
est intéressante d'ici quelques jours
vous emmène également à berlin va partir
à l'ifa vous allez voir ça va être top
parce que on va les rencontrer plein de
marques plein nouveaux produits on va
tester plein de choses on va
probablement tester la caméra d'une
hotte neuf directement à berlin
donc on aura vraiment des décors qui
seront superbes on ira bien sûr à las
vegas pour le cs on ira bien évidemment
faire un tour aussi du côté de new york
[Musique]
oh
on ira faire un tour à barcelone pour le
mwc on est parti il ya pas très
longtemps madrid on va continuer qui
peut à voyager en fonction des
opportunités
donc vous allez voir ça va être vraiment
super qui dit nouvelle saison nouveau
générique dit un peu nouveau format
aussi c'est un nouveau format plus vu
log et non pas que vous raconter ma vie
parce que c'est pas du tout du tout du
tout l'histoire
l'idée c'est de partager la vie d'un
passionné de teck qui vous emmène au
travers de ses voyages découvrir un peu
les nouveautés les nouveaux produits
dont on va mélanger un peu tout ça et va
vous sortir un contenu nouveau et
différent de ce que faisait dernièrement
alors différent oui et non on va
continuer à voir des tests des tests
sont restructurées sensiblement de la
même manière mais vous allez voir va y
avoir pas mal de surprises de choses qui
vont arriver donc vous invite à faire
une chose c'est à vous abonner et à
rester connectés d'ailleurs la
dénomination change
j'aime pas trop la vie d'aviation
youtuber parce que même si youtube
j'adore la plate forme je trouve
vraiment bien elle me permet de
progresser de vous présenter mon travail
est de faire surtout votre en compte
parce que je suis très très heureux de
voir toujours plus nombreuses sont plus
nombreux sur la chaîne et saha croyez
moi c'est la plus belle des récompenses
mais on va changer le terme parce que
prouve que le terme de youtube heures en
faire un peu trop est très restrictif
je préfère un autre terme qui a plus
employée par les américains c'est le
terme de blogueurs donc je ne situe pas
dans la case des youtuber tech mais des
blogueurs tech propose d'ailleurs du
contenu original différents et
complémentaires sont à chaînes d'itv
instagram monsieur underscore greu sur
twitter monsieur gros tout attaché il ya
aussi du contenu se résoudra pas mal de
choses donc des choses qui vont se
mettre en place tout au long de la
saison qui vont être amenées à évoluer
vous invite donc un enjeu mais également
sur ses différentes plateformes et donc
un nouveau format nouveau format parce
que nouveau générique mais surtout on va
rajouter un petit peu de contenu je vous
présentais des hawks
et qu'ils nécessitent pas forcément une
vidéo entière mais qui peuvent être
vraiment intéressant peuvent être des
accessoires des compléments donc ça je
voulais présenterez soit en début de
vidéo soit en fin de vidéo à voir un
petit peu comment ce que tout ça il ya
déjà pas mal de choses qui sont arrivées
la gamme extrêmement lourd je reposte
pas tomber sa place et pèse une tonne va
y avoir donc toutes ces nouveautés
l'homme et on prendra du temps aussi en
fin de certaines vidéos pour répondre à
vos questions
faire des petites faq donc n'hésitez pas
à me poser toutes vos questions en
commentaires ici sous youtube
j'essaierai de vous répondre aussi
directement via le clavier en
commentaire mboso si vos questions sur
twitter @ monsieur dreux je me ferais
vraiment un plaisir d'y répondre devant
la caméra
voilà donc pour toutes ces nouveautés
sur la chaîne pour cette saison numéro 2
je suis très heureux de pouvoir
commencer cette saison numéro deux avec
un produit d'exception parce que
franchement alors même si je n'ai pas
testé j'ai très bien compris de quoi il
s'agissait
j'ai très bien compris le travail qu'a
fait samsung j'ai vu les samsung galaxy
s 9,9 plus en début d'année la se
produit le dock 9 je crois qu'on arrive
sur un produit qui est vraiment sublime
qui est très complet qui permet de faire
énormément de choses le problème de la
batterie qui est un peu faiblard l'année
dernière a été corrigé on va donc tester
ce produit on va l'ouvrir et vous allez
voir à mon avis on n'a vraiment pas être
déçu voici donc la boîte de ce samsung
galaxy note 9
je trouve que le packaging est toujours
extrêmement bien réussi hsa dessous ça
si vous l'avez vu cette couleur est
juste sublime
en fonction de la lumière vous allez
voir c'est vraiment top toujours
extrêmement premium de toute façon pour
un objet de ce prix là il est forcément
extrêmement premium à l'ouverture c'est
vrai qu'il ya tout de suite c'est très
très classieux petite écriture samsung
ici sur le côté là on a le sceau de
sécurité european sim card en unihockey
promis ouverture samsung galaxy note 9
super super super super classe petite
languette sur le côté pour me rattraper
premières sensations c'est vrai que le
produit est super super impressionnant
très très grand très très très très
grand si je compare par rapport à un
iphone 10 qui en plus de ça une coque de
protection rigide sur dessus y'a pas
photo c'est vraiment un smartphone qui
est super un grand à l'intérieur de la
peau
nous avons ici des petit adaptateur usb
usb type ces micro usb usb type c'est le
bloc de charge le câble usb usb type c d
et coûtera kg des protections pour les
oreillettes pour le casque je suppose à
cacher et ici nous avons notre agent
pinky juste là et sur le dessus dit de
prise en main rapide avec toutes les
infos en termes de prise en main il est
juste énorme il est vraiment géant c'est
plutôt cool je suis vraiment très
heureux que samsung a changé et est
passé son capteur d'empreintes digitales
qui était située sur le côté et les mii
en dessous savitrak ans et met les
traces de doigts directement sur
l'appareil photo et c'est franchement
beaucoup mieux et lorsqu'on prend c'est
vrai qu'on leur père beaucoup plus
facilement tout de suite avec le doigt
peut qu'arriver n'a jamais milité
c'était franchement le bordel je sais
pas vous mais moi c'est vraiment un
moment que j'adore le design est
vraiment splendide
l'écran est incurvé sur le côté c'est
vrai que ça lui confère un côté hyper
classieux vraiment très très joli après
ce que vous n'allez pas coupé sur ce
smartphone sont les traces de doigts à
l'arrière c'est un dos en verre
forcément pour la recharge sans fil vous
allez voir des traces de doigts qui vont
finir par apparaître mais bon sang des
habitués actuellement à ce qu'ils en
aient un peu partout vous garder en
dessous une prise directe ça c'est un
excellent point
merci beaucoup ça ne sonne je suis très
content qu'il y ait encore une prise
directe sur un smartphone très haut de
gamme en 2018 de l'usb type c vous avez
bien évidemment ici le style et je
trouve que la couleur du stylet est
vraiment eu peur ce style on va beaucoup
en parler parce que il ya vraiment des
propriétés qui sont incroyables vous
pouvez déclencher les photos à distance
vous pouvez faire des présentations
powerpoint faire pas mal de choses vous
pouvez le pilote à distance s'est
instillé en bluetooth donc ça c'est
vraiment aussi un accessoire qui va
encore plus loin on voit que samsung va
beaucoup plus loin cherche toujours un
petit peu à se réinventer
au travers de ces produits c'est
vraiment super il trouve sa place
extrêmement facilement vous mettez vous
appuyez hop il éclipsé pour appuyer
cette et sortir vous le prenez vous le
tir et point de vue design je trouve
vraiment vraiment super bien réussi
modèle super élégant double capteur
photo ici capteurs simples à l'avant bon
on va éviter de refaire un petit peu un
tour des spécifications techniques
déjà parlé dans une première vidéo de
présentation vous avez ici le bouton
pour l'allumer et pour l'éteindre
ici le bouton qu'on monte et pour
baisser le volume est ici un sourd vous
avez le bouton pour apple explique
malheureusement bixby n'est toujours pas
en français si vous voulez vous répondre
il faut tout simplement lui parle en
anglais avec des wings à whitby while we
did so french a dit buono la france
paris les champs elysées la baguette le
vin rouge
ok je connais tu en voilà bigby ne parle
pas français
néanmoins si vous maîtrisez vraiment la
langue de shakespeare vous avez plein de
choses à faire avec
bon par contre on va pas être un mot
coeur parce que bixby vous faire quand
même pas mal de choses du point de vue
de l'intelligence artificielle vous
activez ici dicks des visions savoir
connaîtra des bouteilles de vin des
monuments de jeu c'est à quoi et ça vous
filera à plein d'informations dessus et
ça c'est quand même plutôt cool
maintenant on attend pas vraiment que
samsung nous sortent enfin bixby en
français et là je crois que ça pourra
séduire encore beaucoup plus de monde
d'autant plus que ces objets d'art se
complète vraiment avec de l'ail chili
avec de l'état et au string c'est à dire
les objets connectés à la maison donc
une fois vous aurez des clients français
et que tous les objets connectés
démocratiseront de plus en plus je pense
notamment aux aléas à vos portes
connecté au phillips ue avec les
ampoules va pas mal de choses ça va être
vraiment vraiment passionnant je pense
que pour l'instant ça me sourit encore
un petit peu de temps pour affiner sa
copie du côté de bixby en français et en
tout cas si quelques temps ça va être le
cas on en parlera énormément de vous et
à faire une chose c'est à rester
connectés et bien sûr vous abonner
mais en tout cas le produit vraiment
premium très beau lorsque je vous
conseille fortement avec un produit de
ce prix là que tu n as plus de 1000
euros et vu la qualité du produit il
faut faire extrêmement attention si vous
voulez pas avoir des déconvenues ils
vont trouver qu'un smartphone
complètement éclaté moi j'ai changer
l'écran de mon smartphone n'est pas très
longtemps on croyez moi vaut mieux se
protéger alors pour vous protéger je
vous conseille fortement de vous équiper
avec des protections vous avez soit la
société d'avoir des bonnes peur comme
celui de rhinau chiffres que vous avez
là qui peut être une solution très
intéressante et là au moins vous de
protéger un peu sur les côtés si vous
voulez vraiment
dans le protéger sur la face arrière ce
que je vous conseille c'est carrément de
prendre une coque dédié vraiment pour
des lacs sinotte 9 une coque en carbone
comme ça ou alors une coque noire toute
simple je sais pas laquelle vous
préférez moi et j'ai une petite
préférence pour la pop au carbone je
vous conseille toujours protéger votre
smartphone même si c'est vrai que comme
il est fait là il est magnifique
effectivement avec ça la recharge par
induction vous l'aurez pas par contre ça
vous évitera quand même qu'ils se
cassent et ça croyez moi ça peut
vraiment vous sauver la vie puis malgré
tout le produit est très esthétique
comme ça donc franchement ça fait
d'ailleurs si un de ses produits dreno
chine vous intéresse vous avez un code
promo en bas d'un description pour les
acheter avec une remise je crois que
c'est à peu près 20% si je vous dis pas
de bêtise ça vous permettra de vous
équiper pour votre smartphone alors pas
forcément que pour le lot moi je pense
que vous pouvez très bien acheter un
autre produit pour vos autres
smartphones mais je vous conseille
vraiment de les protéger parce que sinon
en réparation ça va vous coûter une
petite fortune
la qualité de l'écran est complètement
incroyable je crois que c'est vraiment
le plus bel écran tout cas les plus
beaux écrans que je retrouve en ce
moment sur les smartphones les
contrastes les couleurs la lumière tout
est vraiment juste extra c'est vraiment
une qualité qui est absolument
hallucinantes sur ce smartphone
la qualité des vidéos est complètement
dingue vous pouvez effectivement up
venir zoom est ici dans votre vidéo si
vous voulez retrouver votre bouton
d'accueil vous glisser et il revient bon
ça c'est un grand classique mais la
qualité est vraiment vraiment vraiment
superbe
on n'a absolument rien à lui reprocher
le rendu est super et hâtifs auto tant
au niveau de la couleur qu'au niveau des
lumières autant au niveau tout ce que
vous voulez ce smartphone est juste
incroyable
autre point plutôt positif il a pas
d'encoches certains pour lui reprocher
des bandes sur le haut et des bandes sur
le bas c'est son adn et l'adn de samsung
je trouve pour ma part que c'est
vraiment une très très belle réussite
cet écran est juste sublime
par rapport à beaucoup d'autres qu'on
peut retrouver sur le marché sont
souvent vraiment leur capacité à avoir
des écrans a complètement dingue il faut
dire qu'ils fabriquent eux mêmes
du côté de san sont display et
franchement une fois de plus c'est une
grande réussite
au point que ce premier parcours là
dessus c'est la puissance sonore je
pense effectivement que vous aviez un
seul haut-parleur ici que c'était un
haut parleur mono marque compte pas du
tout c'est là où c'est vraiment
intelligent et que
samsung n'est pas tu m'épates vous avez
un haut parleur ici et le haut parleur
que vous mettez quand vous téléphonez
devient un haut parleur avec de la vraie
puissance ce qui fait que lorsque vous
êtes devant votre smartphone vous avez
vraiment une sensation un peu plus
immersive
même si ce n'est pas effectivement de
l'immersion complète on a quand même une
sensation de spatialisation et ça en
tout cas c'est vraiment intéressant par
exemple je mets ma vidéo duel fait de
cette année vous allez voir la qualité
audio est complètement dingue
[Musique]
la qualité audio est franchement
franchement cool entre le son vous avez
ici avec le haut parleur ici et les
haut-parleurs du bas c'est vrai beaucoup
l'or n'a pas exactement la même
puissance entre la est là mais je vous
dis un effet de spatialisation qui est
plutôt cool maintenant on va tester en
branchant le casque ya la vache
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hyper hyper hyper hyper hyper violent la
puissance sonore déjà franchement est au
rendez vous la qualité est là alors bon
je suis sur une vidéo youtube donc
forcément ont pressé donc je vais pas
avoir le spectre le plus large avec le
plus de puissance mais en tout cas
franchement c'est assez bluffant claude
viau je pense que vraiment ça me semble
être très très très bien réussi sa copie
était surtout je dis une fois de plus le
fait de garder une prise jack
c'est juste top bravo samsung et merci
aux points ce soir tout bonnement
excellent c'est le déverrouillage alors
vous avez plusieurs façons de le
déverrouiller le capteur d'empreintes
digitales à l'arrière qui est
extrêmement réactif attention enfin j'ai
déjà pu voir mais déjà un deux trois ces
extrêmes en un clic vous pouvez ensuite
me débrouiller avec une combinaison
intelligente de reconnaissance faciale
et leur reconnaissance de l'iris c'est
d'ailleurs ce que moi j'ai paramétrer et
je trouve ça vraiment vraiment vraiment
génial pour le déverrouiller la
reconnaissance faciale et avec les
risques il suffit de l'allumer se mettre
en face ça marche bien il ya quelques
petits délai de latence et le moment je
n'ai pas du tout là c'est marrant gelé
parce que les autres fois je n'ai pas du
tout ça va très très vite
est-ce que j'ai les yeux un peu fermé
est ce que je suis peut-être un
contre-jour nager lumière d'un gros spot
là ça se trouve ça vient du spot fait de
leur âge remettre la c1 tête beaucoup
mieux ouais ça va un peu plus vite
alors après ce qui est rigolo c'est que
pourrait que sarko n'est vraiment l'iris
pas ce que je vais faire un peu en mode
comme ça allait nager triche
hélas il n'a pas attention jour les yeux
biscayne si ça marche donc ça fonctionne
extrêmement bien et c'est relativement
bien sécurisé on va maintenant parler du
espagne parce que c'est quand même
l'élément central de ce smartphone du
moins deux grandes nouveautés qui sont
arrivées bien évidemment sur ce s pen
merci donald seul fameuse pelle permet
donc plusieurs choses avec l'espagne à
toute forme et je pouvais faire c'est
découvrir le smartphone en appuyant sur
le bouton ça c'est vraiment génial ça
vous permet à distance lorsqu'il est
fermé verrouillé de contrôler lors que
vous lancez une vidéo sur youtube au
hasard une dernière vidéo sur le chef
vous avez vos vidéos qui se lisent sur
youtube côté de la musique sur spotify
n'importe quelle application vous
appuyer une fois ça mais la pause vous
appuyer une deuxième fois
sam et lectures tout simplement voir
pour vous amuser ron hop hop hop
jour nous en dise à faire des souvenirs
à certains lorsque voulait passer à la
vidéo suivante fait double clic et hop
vous passez à la vidéo suivante qui
n'est pas la mienne qui est celle de
phone android soluval android point très
sympa maintenant lorsque vous voulez
faire des photos directement là là je
suis sur le focus elle fit donc il me
fait un petit côté ben l'euro toujours
là vous voyez avec mon petit j h5 salut
tout le monde j'espère que ça va vous
appuyer une fois ça prend une photo et
vous appuyez deux fois ça change
objectif est salée mais de l'autre côté
là je passe sur l'objectif arrière mais
comme il est appuyé là dessus bien
évidemment on ne voit absolument rien je
rends fait donc un double clic et je
reviens sur l'objectif
avant ça c'est plutôt cool alors vous
avez plein d'infos sur les photos sont
en reparler d'ici quelques temps
notamment la photographe une main ça
vous reconnaît m et ça fait une photo
voilà donc ça c'est plutôt cool photo
j'appuie et j'appuie encore et et voilà
donc ça c'est plutôt cool de pouvoir
piloter avec sa autre truc super
intéressant lorsque vous allez dans
votre galerie de photos qui se situe ici
forces vives la regardez moi cette
tronche
vous pouvez naviguer avec votre stylet
vous appuyer une fois vous passez sur la
suivante
une fois sur la suivante une fois sur la
suivante il ressort la suivante c'est
mon dieu qu'est ce que j'ai fait hop de
cliquer envers marié envie en arrière on
va marier avant arrière avant arrière
avant arrière avant arrière j'arrête
parce qu'on va avoir la nausée d'ici
quelques temps ce système au final
plutôt cool parce qu'il vous permet de
piloter votre galaxy note 9 avec ce
petit objet donc petit objet n'est plus
seulement un stylet mais est réellement
une vraie télécommande et ça c'est
vraiment viré l'innovation majeure cette
année on a eu avec les smurfs & stop
plus la lentille ouverture variable
qu'on retrouve sur lot 9 qui est
vraiment top et je vous dis une fois
plus encore par m6 quelques jours pour
la photo et la vidéo donc vous invite à
rester connectés
le fait d'avoir ce style et à la main
vous appuyer la regarde et hop il est
complètement verrouillé je mets mes de
volaille affiche à l'arrière déjà depuis
la sava le déverrouiller pour moi c'est
vraiment une innovation majeure c'est
vraiment génial
le fait que le style et devienne une
télécommande c'était une fonction qui
paraît au final mais tant qu'on y pense
complètement logique
le fait d'avoir misé bluetooth intérieur
parler vraiment d'apporter encore autre
chose et on voit que papa repas stand by
step comme des réseaux américains on
avance
elle ment avec ce genre de produit et
c'est vraiment génial
d'autant plus qu'il faut savoir que
lorsque votre stylet ressort directement
hop
lorsque vous partez avec le stylet que
vous oubliez le style est quelque part
où partent avec le smartphone y avoir
une alarme il à se mettre à sonner pour
vous dirai a été oublié quelque chose
vous fait un petit retour en arrière
vous allez récupérer le stylet et c'est
franchement bien pas trop quoi dire a
toujours pratique là dessus sur le style
et on l'avait déjà l'année dernière avec
les notes 8 c'est la possibilité up de
pouvoir tout commander ici alors
savourons l'a déjà vu hein c'est pas une
nouveauté cette année vous avez la
capture pour faire des sélections
intelligente de la traduction vous
sélectionnez un texte ça vous fait de la
traduction toujours les petits messages
à nîmes et ça c'est mon vrai coup de
coeur je trouve ça trop mignon value
fait des petits hop des petits dessins
des petits coeurs vous pouvez l'envoyer
à qui vous voulez je trouve ça so sweet
y est je trouve que voilà ça fait partie
des petites innovations et des choses
sympas à faire avec ce type de produits
mais la puissance qu'est ce que dit la
puissance dans cette machine vous avez
un exynos 9810 à l'intérieur qu'à danser
jusqu'à 2007 gigahertz maximum il est
couplé à 6 go de ram
aux états unis vous trouvez si vous
allez au sein du si vous vivez aux états
unis ont probablement aussi au canada et
au québec d'ailleurs si vous êtes au
canada dites moi en commentaire si c'est
vraiment pour vous soit un exynos soit
plutôt comme je le pense lust un dragon
845 comme on peut le retrouver aux états
unis vous invite à marquer tout ça
directement bas en commentaire en terme
de puissance franchement il n'a rien à
envier aux autres c'est aujourd'hui l'un
des processeurs les plus puissants qu'on
peut retrouver l'exynos 9810 une vraie
bête de pompe est peu utilisée avec des
jeux gourmands alors que son utilisation
je dirais classique email réseaux
sociaux photos vidéos regarder les
vidéos il explique ce compagnie tout ce
que vous voulez il tournera sans aucun
problème comme je dirais aujourd'hui 90
% des smartphones qui sont vendus sur le
marché erp 84,85 pas dire de conneries
mais comme je dirais l'ensemble des
produits disponibles sur le marché pour
des applications standard il aura
absolument aucun problème par contre si
vous allez chercher un peu plus loin
avec déjà un peu plus gourmand même si
effectivement les smartphones ne sont
pas des consoles on peut les utiliser
pour jouer parce que vous n'êtes plus en
plus d'éditeurs qui vous mettre des jeux
de plus en plus gourmands donc forcément
on cherche d'ailleurs un peu plus de
puissance sans forcément aller sur un
black stars de chez sony ou alors sur un
réseau fon on peut aller sur des
solutions comme celle ci qui est
vraiment un excellent smartphone qui est
très équilibré se trouve pas ce que vous
allez être aussi bien satisfait du point
de vue de la photo de la vidéo mais ça
une fois de plus on va en parler d'ici
quelques jours vous invite à rester
connectés et à vous abonner
mais vous allez avoir une puissance pour
jouer quelque chose qui va répondre
extrêmement rapidement et en plus
beaucoup d'autonomie plus d'une journée
d'autonomie avec une batterie de 4
millions par ailleurs c'est un peu le
point de regret il a aidé à revenir sur
nos tweets une batterie qui est elle un
petit peu en demi-teinte parce que je ne
sais pas si vous en souvenez honore pas
à chaque fois
damon a très bien parlé mais avec 9,7 ça
me semblait vraiment un très gros revers
à cause des problèmes de la batterie
donc avec le 28 son marché un petit peu
sur des oeufs on joue un petit peu la
sécurité là ils reviennent en force
ils montrent vraiment toutes leurs
capacités à apprendre de leurs erreurs
et a progressé à sortir des produits
complètement hallucinant avec 59 donc je
trouve que ce note 9 c'est un petit peu
l'équation parfaite entre le note 8 es8
es9 pour du gaming pour la photo pour
belle autonomie vous avez un produit qui
est super équilibré et qui est vraiment
complète les tops non justement pour
parler de performance on va regarder un
petit peu maintenant ce qui se passe
lorsqu'on va chercher à jouer à un jeu
en terme d'expérience de jeu pour ça
vraiment vraiment fluide ça répond super
bien pour être tous les côtés il ya
aucun lag aucune latence
c'est vraiment top up je peux faire ce
que je alors je suis pas un excellent un
gamer je pense que vous allez vous en
doutez néanmoins je suis perdu néanmoins
je trouve que c'est plutôt cool alors
attendre parce que je suis là voilà je
trouve que c'est quand même malgré tout
super cool ça répond super bien et ça
c'est juste au top là je trouve que ceux
des résidences neuves est vraiment super
bien réussi que ce soit au niveau de
l'écran qui est vraiment génial une
certification il pèse 68 qui vous
protège contre l'eau entre la poussière
vous avez un style et qui sert de
télécommande un appareil photo même si
on va les tester dans quelques jours qui
en tout cas a l'air d'être vraiment
séduisant et connaissant l'appareil
photo du s9 plus croyez moi c'est
vraiment un truc qui est extraordinaire
mais ça une fois de plus on va vérifier
d'ici quelques jours un écran génial
extrêmement fluide très puissant en plus
il a pas dans coche il a une prise jack
il a une recharge rapide on y laisse
bêtise c'est une batterie énorme de 4000
milliards erreur très clairement ce
galaxy note 9 est une vraie bête de
compet alors certains pourront lui
reprocher d'être trop près du s9 plus ou
qui pas d'énorme évolution mise à part à
la batterie un peu plus grosse et il a
par le style et par rapport aux notes 8
je trouve pour moi que ce galaxy note 9
est plutôt l'aboutissement de certains
produits et se situe à mi chemin entre 1
28 et 1 es9 plus vous avez au final un
excellent résultat alors si vous avez
déjà un ace 9,9 plus il est absolument
aucun intérêt à moins d'avoir réellement
besoin du stylet n'allait pas acheté ce
produit quand même plus de 1000 euros si
vous avez un autre tweet je pense pas
que ce soit nécessairement le moment de
changer si par contre vous avez un
ancien produit un ancien smartphone si
vous avez un produit autre que de
samsung vous pouvez y aller les yeux
fermés effectivement qui lie pas cadeau
cadeaux c'est pas le produit le moins
cher du marché
mais en terme de qualité il est vraiment
hyper hyper cohérent que ce soit l'écran
les photos la vidéo le jeu la puissance
la batterie c'est vraiment un produit
qui est extraordinaire et vous serez
absolument pas déçu d'ailleurs dit moi
en commentaire ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez vous ce galaxy note
9 par rapport à la présentation par
rapport à ce test par rapport à ce que
vous avez pu glaner comme info à droite
à gauche
est ce que vous trouvez plutôt cool est
au contraire vous reste un peu sur notre
faim mais en tout cas je vous dis je le
trouve vraiment vraiment vraiment super
ce congrès est un petit peu sont
toujours les fameux strass de douane sur
un dos
on ne peut absolument pas y couper comme
en plus le fait que le decs sont
intégrés avec un adaptateur usb type ch
délit c'est vraiment super bien je
trouve que ça me semble vraiment dans le
bon sens avec ce typologie de produits
j'ai hâte de voir ce qui va se passer en
2019 d'ailleurs on va y aller on y sera
enfin en 2019 je vous invite donc tout
de suite à vous abonner à rester
connectés parce que vous allez voir ça
va être super cool merci d'avoir regardé
cette grande vidéo de présentation du
samsung galaxy note 9 et de cette
rentrée de cette saison numéro deux
vient de rendez vous dès demain pourra
découvrir le poteau von dutch iommi vous
allez voir à mon avis on n'est pas au
bout de nos surprises
à bientôt
[Musique]